hello Ben hello there so Luke how's
Akhil welcome happy happy Tuesday I was
glad that you jumped on that because I
actually don't know what right yeah
surprise to absolutely nobody modern
warfare 2 campaign is out maybe one of
the weirdest like announcements I don't
know like before they officially
announced that the whole game was up on
like YouTube
yeah people had already done like full
of it real like real weird anyway we're
gonna just hop in here and check this
game out I'm picking the second mission
I'm skipping the like the training
trading mission I question what do you
wear does want to work for two's
campaign rank for you I think it was one
of the last ones that I kind of played
and was actually like into it's good
it's also kind of like the tipping point
where I feel like they went really kind
of like summer blockbuster movie with it
I would 100% agree we're like the
original modern warfare was sort of tame
and it's and it's approach for for Call
of Duty this is where they're like what
if we just made every action movie ever
and it's great I love it
but it's it's a very different tone from
the original modern warefare but
definitely and then they kind of
continued that even more with modern
warfare for sure for sure I I think I
like yeah and mine were for three I was
kind of pretty pretty whatever on but to
to my play the most but it's mostly the
cam the multiplayer I like played the
multiplayer up time but I did I did play
I think I'm I don't recall a 500 percent
at all the achievements but I definitely
like I think I beat this thing on like
the veteran difficulty or whatever oh I
definitely did veteran phone all the
internal yeah I'm really quick for
people to check his Bravo six brought it
up have to ask what is it supposed to be
coming out it's out now it's out now I'm
pointing for ya it's a timed exclusive
for a month which is weird and weird and
it also is weird that they are
distinctly saying it is campaign
remastered there's no multi no bomb
supplier there it is the Pro point is
this real this is very real invisible
soldier yeah same as the same as all of
us it looks good I mean you know it it
doesn't look as good as obviously like
last year's modern warfare not to be
confused with the other modern warfare
but he looks in line with how good the
modern warfare the original oh god the
2007 Modern Warfare's remaster there's a
lot of tons oh boy that's just a mess
yeah it looks it looked pretty good like
that looks really really good and this
is also I'd say looks as good as bad
it's one of those things where you play
it and you're looking at me like oh yeah
this is how I remember modern warfare 2
looking like it looked it looks about
this and then you actually go back and
look at modern warfare 2 and you're like
oh no that's this looks significantly
better yeah I'm actually watching a
secondary stream through discord to keep
up with what you're doing and even just
looking through this stream I can tell
that it looks better but how much is is
this by the way
oh only 20 bucks not bad it's not bad
not bad I'm exactly I'm surprised I was
really expecting it to be like 30 knows
like I I was definitely ready for you to
say like 40 even yeah to be honest 24
considering that it is like fully
remastered in the visuals like abets
that's not bad
I'm okay with that yeah
Brandon Hernandez says I want a hard
copy of this not digital yeah well maybe
if if they do follow through and make
all the multiplayer stuff maybe I'll do
like a thing with both package I want
them to redo the multiplayer because
again I think that was one aware if
you're too small to players the one I
personally spend the most time in but
they also did the original modern
warfare remastered multiplayer real
dirty yes and I I don't like I really
liked it when it first came out and then
they added all that like
microtransaction they made you pay for
the new guns in the games you pay for
the mat the DLC maps they made you pay
more money than you original also worth
mentioning while you were testing this
earlier you saw an option to inspect
your gun
oh yeah I'll show that which wasn't in
the game at all which makes me think
they're definitely gonna be selling
skins if there is a multiplayer mode
there's no reason for you to inspect
your gun in a single-player game yeah
it's real weird it was a strange
editions yeah one I wonder if this is
how it'll break down $20 for the
campaign $20 for the multiplayer than
$10 for SpecOps and then as much as
you're willing to spend for
microtransactions yeah yeah it's all
just speculation at this point put right
like if they do do the multiplayer I see
no reason why they wouldn't treat it the
same way they did the other one which I
think would personally sour my interest
in playing it unfortunately but we'll
see you know I'm also wondering if this
is like a play because they realized
everyone's at home right now and they're
trying to put something out that people
can play before they everything finished
that's a good question but then at the
same time there's the weird exclusivity
you think you'd want to give it to
everybody like that's a weird like Sony
deal type thing that I'm like pretty
black
I don't know I get that that deal was
probably made like way in advance but uh
no ma'am I think everyone should be able
a video games that they want to play
thank you video games - what if it is
like a really well done multiplayer
where it's like cross-platform and stuff
like what if what if they're gonna do
like good good shows you know to get
that still sorted out that'd be pretty
cool actually if they did include cross
play that'd be right yeah I'm here for
it huh
yeah it is weird though that they chose
to not put it on PC and Xbox at the same
time
oh all right it's been a hot minute
since I played called ad game I was
gonna say even even with modern warfare
I didn't even like stay on it that much
no I played it that initial wait way
more of black and up short I think black
ops is is definitely my favorite like
series our share in the Call of Duty
series but having that that like better
royale that was pretty pretty wacky
mixed with the zombies mode I really
like zombies and black house
also I don't know if people can hear me
but Keith David I forgot he was in this
game gear I love me some Keith David
moogles saying that we don't understand
that Sony paid off I mean no no I mean
no that's but yeah like there's there's
nothing that like what it's not even a
thing to think about I mean of course
for sure it's just yeah I guess we're
more commenting on how awkward the
release setup for this is yeah it's it's
like whatever you know we expect that
like I know they have like their call
duty deal and you know Xbox did it in
the 360 era as well with like exclusive
like you know time DLC releases and
stuff but yeah just the timing of it
feels awkward it's one of those things
where I just feel like as time goes on
things like exclusive deals feel more
antiquated yeah that's just me yeah like
we there there's no kind of lead-up to
this outside of like we're deep things
right you don't even know if they are
bringing back anything else on the
campaign but you've you've got that that
weapon inspect though yeah yeah I'll
show that in a sec this is such a weird
thing yeah so like here you just inspect
your anytime hey I have this gun what's
this gun look like wow oh man look at
that clip OSAP
I'm really excited to so I remember this
first level just being kind of okay but
I did go to some places and I'm very
really doing I'm really excited just to
replay it because I I definitely member
this game having some [ __ ] happen in it
that's fun yeah
like we said it's very blockbuster yeah
I mean you've got a defend burger town
can't offend burger town man also
apparently I saw some place there
someone was talking about Russia's
blocking sales of the game because the
whole alter nationalist thing yeah so I
wonder if if that's true that's that's a
heck of a thing gets in that rally point
let's do it
Bob Bob Jones in the [ __ ] how's it going
because the whole thing here is you're
like playing as you're playing as the
dude who then does the gets killed in
the no Russian mission right like it's
not the whole setup here yeah I'm pretty
sure I remember right Jacob
actually brings up a really good point
they feel like that there won't be a
multiplayer released for this because a
lot of modern warfare 2 maps are being
added to the new game Oh sort of like
this is a fair point it's like a halo
anniversary situation where they didn't
went when halo 1 anniversary originally
came out on the 360 they never ported
the multiplayer instead they had like a
bunch of the like some of the best Maps
redone in Rio and you like had access to
the Reach's multiplayer when you bought
that game which was real weird yeah if
that's a good thing to consider always
voiced by what's wasn't exactly on top
of it back when I played this originally
remember this is a it's an aliens trying
to try to think of who it is the show
probably knows Lance Hendricks Hendricks
right are you
I think it's vendrick son sounds right
oh I'll go with it
anyway I just don't recall him voicing
Shepard he totally could have and I'm
just missing remember oh here we go
our boy this is this is Louisville that
they showed off during the e3
presentation yeah
and I don't I can't forget that cuz it
was wild play your boy roach everyone's
favorite Witcher character was actually
in Call of Duty before mm-hmm that's
true it's the horse right there yeah I
remember like Call of Duty campaigns for
like a huge like moment for Yuri you
always were like oh man like they're
gonna can't wait till the dough to see
the campaign sequence they're gonna have
I mean this this mission just has so
much in it like the the climbing's got
its own mechanic there's a bit of a
stealth thing that happens you get the
whole snowmobile chase at the end gasps
it's so good it's real good okay
yep yeah
kind of Lobby and modern warfare once
and Jake Decker was on the other team I
recognize his gamertag he's good at God
Wow
he's ready God he he is very good at con
he's been playing a lot of a modern
warfare yeah I was about to say since it
sounds like a lot of people have kind of
taken a bit of a break from Rainbow six
and they've kind of moved over into coal
Duty for a bit alright we climbed that
thing oh yeah
see you on the far side then why do I
jump with ya I have to jump as well oh
yeah yeah yeah then he like grabs he or
whatever it's all coming back to me yeah
this is this is kind of just like it's a
good remaster cuz this is how I imagined
it all looking in my head exactly you're
like yeah yeah it totally looked like
this it would look so good back in the
day and now you're like oh oh then you
have the heartbeat sensor then you know
the alien heartbeat sensor so cool there
was a lot of really cool equipment they
put in this one the heartbeat sensor
they put in the ballistic knife is a
option yeah oh no the ballistic knife I
think was actually maybe that was those
black ops actually I think either way
the heartbeat sensors were cool all my
Call of Duty knowledge is just melting
together now because it's all been so
long oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you get that
ball do that dab commando pro I was on
that day one
people hated me what it was black ops
one okay cool okay
the knife yeah I think black ops one was
the the ballistic knife cuz I remember
running around that's its the Snowy
level in black ops and just kind of like
doing the thing yeah was it it's the I'd
always use the the SOCOM with the TAC
knife and commando Pro and I would use
well cuz the silk almost the gun from
Metal Gear and I thought it was cool and
I'd also used the dual 1887 s because
they're just the coolest thing so when
you shoot my bed knots all good I'm the
one who said that it was in modern
warfare 2 so like ain't no thing we have
no idea absolutely that's the thing
we're we're pretty in the dark as well
as far as this whole thing goes yeah it
just sort of happened the only info we
had were the leaks that everyone else
saw exactly there's a fun thing twitch
for a long time had a promotional video
and in their promotional video was a
clip of me playing Call of Duty ghosts
and I wish that they would have picked
literally anything else so I I deliver
with people studying me like pictures of
it like when they walk by the twitch
booth like III or pax be like oh there's
you plan play Call of Duty I'm like most
uncharacteristic like example of me
doing a stream this is fake flash this
is real is happening right from your
eyes I'm doing a terrible job being
stealth here
I no one's found you yet surprisingly so
for anyone who doesn't know this got
announced and released all today and is
only available on the PlayStation 4 at
the moment but it it will come to the
Xbox and PC and like I'm up I believe
it's a month exclusive and it is just
the campaign for $20 no news on like the
multiplayer or the spec ops stuff yeah
official Pro Cod streamer oh god don't
know anything but think I want to be a
professional I want to be a pro Deadly
Premonition streamer that sounds pretty
good this looks awful that's cuz of the
snow it's a lot of snow it's just cuz
you can't see anything cuz the snow it
actually looks really great and you know
what it's getting released this is out
now yeah it's on PlayStation yep yep yes
far you can go get pick this up see this
is why announcing and releasing
something on the same day like this it
is like a weird choice because no one
knows about it it's just yeah
20 dollars for just the campaign
Activision strikes again it's true
they're out here a month I gotta buy ps4
yeah if you like that sometimes there we
go
it's it's like no we've no clue about
multiplayer I will say they're learning
it's less terrible than making the whole
campaign and like part of like a like a
collection like remember it was part of
like the global legacy edition of
infinite for like half a year or
whatever the heck like that was that was
way worse and them saying that they'd
never put it out separately and then
then putting it out separately after
they ran into the ground and ruined it
yep which is like we all saw that coming
I didn't see I honestly didn't see them
taking a Call of Duty for remaster and
adding weapons to the multiplayer that
was that was a level I was not expecting
them to go to you but you know what they
did take the scenic route this guy oh
we're doing at door breach let's just
say the big thing for this one was door
breaches to I feel like yeah this is one
door breaches became a thing they did
the the slow-motion like you move into
the room and gotta take everyone out I
remember that killing like one of the
trailers yeah was the best to me I agree
majestic spider I like black ops one a
lot apparently it's $30 in Canada that's
that's a power those Canada Canada
prices conversion rate no good okay I'm
getting caught up in actually just kind
of like watching this against in the car
yeah yeah I know what's coming up I also
like they're like Plan B and you as the
player don't know what's happening but
they automatically switch you over to
this c4 thing yeah you're like okay got
it figured it out that's also a good
thing to kind of note too if they do
make the multiplayer cross-platform
having it come out around the time that
all the other platforms get it would
make sense Wow sure there's a lot of
good arguments going a lot of different
ways for this yeah it's all over the
place but all we can do is sit here in
theory craft because we'd even know this
game was real until the other day
I mean someone like posted the trailer
yesterday and I was like asses I could
this actually be a remaster it says it
but I don't know if it was a race
surprise when I heard that it was a
thing because I'm like yeah that seems
like a thing that they would do yeah the
real question is are they gonna bother
remastering three is there enough
nostalgia for three like are they gonna
do it for the sake of just closing out
the trilogy like what's what do you
think I feel like maybe they will and
then it'll be another opportunity for
them to sell the modern warfare like
care package edition as all three alone
maybe I want some black ops remasters
that's what I need wasn't there no no no
no it wasn't that a black ops it's that
the rebooting black ops I was
which I don't know how I feel down that
that's a weird I don't know I feel about
call of duty just rebooting all of its
franchises again yeah like I know people
always joke about like all the B's bit
bankrupt for you know whatever whatever
but like that that to me is a level of
like okay one what all you're doing is
really mastering your your faith your
best games maybe says a little something
oh yeah the the special editions that
had the the night-vision goggles
yeah who was it that had a was it ice-t
Ice Cube no ice-t I think was ice Teague
at it probably yeah
Ice Cube is um black ops because he was
in black ops yeah his ice is iced tea in
this one did iced tea ever show up in a
call nudie game oh I don't remember I
know he was in Gears of War maybe it
maybe I'm yeah me I'm thinking Gears of
War oh look at that oh it was good oh
man it looks like it's almost time to
get on those some ovals and yeah ride
down let's do it my dude
all right I remember the first time I
did this I I this part was easy to mess
up so hopefully I can do it I remember
there being like an achievement tied to
doing this a certain way it was like you
you had to do the whole thing without
letting off of the gas or something or
one one try or not shooting anyone
there's something tied to it because I
remember doing it a bunch of times and I
don't think it was for my health because
I remember being frustrated by it yeah I
remember doing this on veteran and being
very like frustrated maybe that was just
it doing on adventuring
can't even tell us remaster might just
be meet it there's also a bit that gets
lost in the fact that we're streaming it
like yeah in front of you is a
completely different I'm I would say
everything's one it's the stream like
there's it's definitely different you
know watching it first playing it
yourself to I would recommend go back
and actually to look at how the original
one looked because it's one of those
things that we've decided a couple times
but you look at it and you're like oh
yeah this this just looks like how I
remember it and then you go back and
watch it and you realize how much better
actually does look it's like textures
being great I'm looking forward to
people making a couple of graphics
comparisons and stuff like that I do
think once you see them side by side you
will realize wow okay I did that in one
holy crap
thank you I remember that being way
harder I think it I really think it's
because my memory is all about doing it
on veteran that might be it for me to
the mission is the big one
but they wasn't that early on yeah it's
pretty early in the game yeah no
multiplayer in it at least for now if
they ever decided to do it later on yeah
this is it man this man doesn't flinch
it torture human trafficking or genocide
he's not boiled to a flag or a country
or any set of ideals he trades blood
from money rich blood for money you
cannot if you've already seen this
cutscene you can skip it but if you do
they make you watch it the first time
you gotta get the context for what's
going on I guess that's what made me put
the game down and I never finished it I
need to finish it
dang deadly I believe in you veteran in
call Call of Duty veteran difficulties
have always been those weird
difficulties that I
feel like are intentionally not balanced
you know I mean yeah like they've
they've gotten a lot better over time
well like I guess back when I cared to
do it like some of those were oh pretty
brutal he said the thing he said the
thing so I'll admit the first time I
played this I didn't shoot I didn't
either
I knew was going continue I think you
get an achievement for not shooting so I
think that might be where I will not be
that like it's just kind of yeah I'm not
gonna shoot I want that achievement so
let's I might've also like maybe just
shot like at the roof to kind of place
oh hey I'm totally you know I want to
get into it because I remember how much
of a weird stink this this thing had
when uh when it came out but honestly
it's I never thought it was a big deal
it I don't think it came across as like
crazy is like you know that like
sensationalizes people made it out to be
I think it's just sort of whatever yeah
I also think it was too big good yeah I
also don't think it's it's honestly like
that interesting either like as a like a
shock thing I'm like yeah I don't know
it's kind of whatever to me yeah let's
be personally I'm run out their own
opinions yeah you know it is great
though the airport level in monomorphic
two's multiplayer it's really true and
you know what I actually don't even
think about the fact that it's basically
based off of this I don't either but
it's a real good really brought
everything around the holy holy
hey look his burger town
found it it's bits the real burger town
hey what up guys I sure am a bad guy
check to check it out I'm reloading my
gun
look look how cool my gun looks I'm
gonna inspect it yep that's a
good-looking gun it's still weird that
you can inspect it I don't I don't like
it's real weird about this guy what's
this look like okay are you gonna shoot
others there's a there's a trophy tied
to not shoot it yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
get that trophy it's like that's that's
nothing for reason not to
it doesn't like make anything go quicker
no it doesn't make anything go quicker
you get something out of it for not
doing it I assume the achievements still
in here so because if I remove assume
they didn't change any of it yeah I like
warzone I haven't played a lot of it
recently but I actually haven't tried
it's really it's it's an interesting
better rail but I think it lasts longer
than I want a better ROI all the last
I've heard like games take twenty to
thirty minutes and that's it's not too
much in the grand scheme of things but
you know could be something else yeah
man all you guys are a real real hurt
about all of this what I mean just I
mean it's exactly what you think people
being upset that we're not shooting
things I want the achievement though
yeah where people are gonna do what they
do all right
okay it has multi clear it does not have
multiplayer
all right guys hurry up now I believe at
this point there is a point where you do
have to shoot right like like don't like
now you're fighting I don't I don't
think so cuz you you head underground
and then you get to the the van and then
he gets you oh okay
I for whatever reason I remember there
being a part here where I couldn't
remember though if you're supposed to
shoot here and r2 for the achievement I
mean if if we really wanted to play it
safe we would have skipped playing this
entirely because it's an option and we
didn't do that oh yeah yeah I'm not yeah
yeah totally I have the option to skip
it I'm not gonna do that I'll care I'm
trying to remember if this counts for
the achievement or not apparently there
is no achievement
there's no achievement that's totally an
itchy no that no there isn't
actually now that I think I'm I think
it's something else you can because the
fact that you can skip it means that in
tiny achievements oh may be confusing it
with something then am i confusing that
was something else
I swear there was an achievement
associated with it I must be confusing
it is there's no way they'd have won
because if someone chose not to play it
now that totally makes sense
I wonder what I'm confusing it with them
oh well knew there was no no I actually
thought there was I totally thought
there was
and then the realization happened where
you can't bar people out from getting it
yeah what difficulties of some is just
some I don't really play on Hardinge
right that's leaves the one after but
for the purposes of the stream just
playing on good old regular see you call
up the new tube I still call it the pro
pipe i new tube was definitely the more
common one
oh yeah but you got a [ __ ] plate it's
a footnoted on them yeah I like I like
that one
that's pretty good well I think I think
pro pipe actually came from Halo Reach
because the the grenade launcher was
actually like a bit of a skill thing it
was renamed launcher is actually really
difficult because it had the EMP blasts
on it too so I just gotta carry that
around
Oh are we clear
I don't know wolf like like you're
saying earlier we didn't know this was
happening until it happens so we don't
have any more information that anyone
else does we have no idea the only thing
we can do is kind of speculate based off
of the fact like it's called
campaign remastered so maybe they're
trying to separate them out it could be
a whole bunch of other stuff but right
now this is just a a twenty dollar
remaster of the campaign as it stands
price can change depending on what
region your input that's where we are
indeed is John they're using a scuf
controller not a scuf controller yeah
this looks like a like a weird modified
controller that people used for like
trick shots and Oh having access to
other buttons it's a it's a wild time I
love like like these two weird 3d
printed like spider attachments you can
do to like people have weird setup like
you like to make your own elite
controller type of situation yeah it's
it's wild all right all right here level
said no multiplayer not to change the
player videos from the recent release of
warzone I can see that being thing I
haven't seen any I also haven't read
anything about this besides just knowing
that it's a campaign only and it's got a
staggered release and only on ps4 right
now but that makes sense to not want to
draw people away from your game that
you've got going on anyway I was also
waiting for the other two to come out
would make sense yeah I always thought
this whole like the narrative conceit
that hey they found one American soldier
there so the entirety so it's gotta be
the Americans but but then that just
immediately leads to the entirety of
Russia invading the US I'm like that's a
bit of a stretch it's but but as you
said before it's very much a action
movie plot yeah so you're just like okay
sure yeah that sounds like something
that would happen in a Michael Bay movie
ah the the REO level yeah I'm slowly
remembering all the different levels are
there real level is a real big I do hope
that we get to the point where we get to
defend burger town though I feel like
that was late in the game yeah
unfortunately that's kind of midway
through I don't know if we'll get there
in time but it is worth saying that if
you are enjoying yourself hanging out
here you should definitely subscribe to
the channel so you don't miss a single
stream that we do we stream every
weekday at 2 p.m. Pacific it could be
new games that get dropped on us without
any sort of heads-up like call duty
modern warfare 2 remastered or just
whatever else is kind of cool going out
at the time I we usually don't show John
Luke and I every Friday where we play
games with you guys and this week we we
weren't quite sure what we're doing
we're tossed around the idea of maybe
doing PSO that'd be fun because you said
it's an open beta sorry I can play yeah
the Phantasy Star Online OH to open beta
is happening on the Xbox and they
actually have a like an event coming up
for this weekend for teaming up and if
you do like 5 missions with people in
your party you get a piratehat and it's
free for people I think you have to have
Xbox Live Gold but that could be a fun
time if you're into that or you like us
out of that might be what we're doing on
Friday if you are wanting to get ahead
and jump start on it well we're on ship
to ship 2 is where the party's at
the algorithm has chosen us oh boy okay
I'll press sounds so it sounds so
ominous you have been chosen oh yeah so
I've been playing a lot of PS oh I
really picked like the worst it's the
best and worst time to realize that
you're really into JRPGs oh yeah going
hard right
you've been playing a the og Final
Fantasy 7 and prep for the remake right
yeah I I was like alright I'm just gonna
play up to midgar's so I can play the
content that is in the remake and then I
kept going it also played dragon quest
11 I'm also starting up for sona 5 again
nice i have my copy on the way persona
I'm very excited to play it but I'm sure
that the people who are here to see Call
of Duty are there I know there's
definitely a cross-section somewhere oh
that's real one to one audience this was
also a pretty good map I remember yeah
this one was really good in the
multiplayer cause it had a lot of
verticality in it
yeah I also remember it explicitly
because of my tech knife commander Pro
hang off of rooftops on the people I
love that
hello uh yeah
is this a new engine I don't think so it
looks like it's whatever engine they had
the original modern warfare running on
so I don't think it's the the new engine
as last year's modern warfare
yeah there's no spec ops to chicken
there it is only Vaughn he's not doing
anything wrong
dang
brought up brought up getting into a
Final Fantasy game and hit with the you
guys are unbearable that's fair I called
it cops no multiplayer why should I buy
this I mean I'm not trying to sell you
on it or anything but I mean it's just
$20 for a campaign if you really want to
go through it again it's pretty much it
it's exactly what you think it is it's
kind of cool to go back and do it again
I don't know if I'll buy it maybe I'll
wait for if they do like a full version
of it cuz I'd like to play the
multiplayer right they've got some
pretty good memories of that I'm excited
to play Resident Evil 3 I'm in here and
I saw the reviews and I saw everyone
talking about it I'm still kind of
stoked uh so um I played it I can yeah I
will say that uh while it didn't hit me
the same way it did with resin evil to
remake I still think it's it's a it's a
good game it's not a bad game by any
means and I think your expectations are
gonna really depend on like what you're
looking for in a Resident Evil if that
makes any sense because like there's so
many Resident Evil's at this point and
like you know there's more action ones
there's more horror ones more puzzling
ones like I would say this is kind of a
weird one where like just like with the
original it's sort of like this
in-between between like the slower of
two and the more like action-oriented
four and I think if you're if you're if
you understand that going in you're
gonna have like a good time with it and
I know you really like the original
version of three so I think you'll enjoy
it yeah I also am one of the weird
people that's probably gonna have a
really good time with resistance as I
actually really enjoyed that
it's just dudes everywhere and I'm
totally good memories reinstall game and
try it again it's horrible compared to
modern titles I don't think it's
horrible what res developer overblown
resident evil 3
no okay Diddy I mean it's it's not a
thing for everyone I guess oh it's it's
still call of duty call duty pretty much
is it's kind of the same thing yeah like
exactly what you think I know what I'm
expecting yeah do they plan to release
multiplayer in the future no word no
word on it we can only only speculate
based off of what we're seeing in this
and I I feel like they may be planning
on it eventually oh there's a whole
bunch of God Jesus oh I forgot about
that
brown comfortable that made me yeah I'm
not a fan of it just gotta do it
otherwise they get you there are so many
people asking if this is a real thing
I promise you this is a real thing it's
just so weird that they just dropped it
this morning
no it's an early April Fool's Day joke
guys we made we recreated all of the
first couple of missions just just to
fool you huge shout out to the boys back
at game spa who who helped develop this
game we were proud to announce that we
are now the first of call of duty yeah
please look forward to it
April Fool's we're making holiday
together dang there was that could have
been it yeah I'll just go over all the
stuff again for anyone who's just coming
in that doesn't know what's what's
happening
it is a just announced just released all
today remaster of Modern Warfare 2 s
campaign no multiplayer no SpecOps it's
$20 in the US ps4 only for a month
ps4 only for now it will come out a
month later on PC and Xbox it's a lot of
info to get out of the way it really is
and the you've got people rotating in
and out so I'm trying to like make sure
we hit everyone with it because I know
people are like oh what is this what's
happening and I want to be as helpful as
I can it's it's out now if you want to
play the campaign sea otter the samurais
saying exactly this that's nail on the
head they could have advertised this
better didn't know anything about it
yeah I completely agree that it was a
real botched like the idea of like hey
we're gonna like stealth release it like
you know surprise good in theory I feel
like they could have executed it way
better there's still a big part of me
that thinks maybe they're trying to do
the whole package and maybe they
finished the campaign so early that they
just broke it off as a separate thing
but again just speculation was this
mating dreams welcome to our dreams yes
that would have been good that again the
entirety of modern warfare 2 remastered
and dreams dream masters oh is that what
you called remasters maiden dreams
during masters its what I'm calling them
now people yelling
does this reverse version look better
the bank compatible version yes I'm sure
it does I will I will say right now it
totally does there you go
we're playing that like not too long ago
cuz it just came out like last year I
got moved over like last year not came
out oh yeah and they also that this is
gonna sound real GameStop e of me but if
you buy it now you get access to the
ghost skin in modern warfare sec i guess
you have a modern warfare 2 ghost skin
along with some modern warfare weapons
hello hold on hold on there we go there
you go it's terrible I think I know they
used to do a Kimbo stuff like all the
time and it seems like it's kind of died
down honestly not that great oh no my my
main weapon of choice in black ops 1 was
duo scorpions multi plays a different
story campaign I never found them
particularly useful I don't know they're
like kind of fun
least on the hard difficulties guys
giving away codes no we didn't even get
coats yeah we didn't get any codes you
you had to buy this to bring it to the
people to let them know oh yeah is this
co-op it is not Robert now unless they
put out spec ops later on which is cool
that's a bummer because I really really
like spec ops and it's very good
oh my god I know I know
trying to murder people Oh where's it
brings up a good point kind of Sony's
like there they used to be like really
really bad about like the kind of anti
consumer stuff
yeah I guess them having exclusives for
this for a month is kind of a thing
they've gotten better though like before
they didn't do any cross-play stuff and
now they're willing to do it who Sony
yeah gathered they're weird I feel like
they're there they're definitely the
most anti consumer of all three of the
the main companies but I feel like
they've made improvements I think
they've made improvements there's still
some weird stuff they have like now what
was it I was thinking of the other day
like no well yeah I don't know they've
gotten better
like I mean they're starting to put out
like some exclusives on like PC which is
kind of cool like a horizon is good
they're slowly getting there slowly
getting better about it for sure
what's the framerate like looks like
it's had some dips on the stream I think
it's it's pretty much a solid 64 yeah
that's uh if you're seeing any dips that
is just the stream I imagine because it
is smooth uh 64 which is something I've
always appreciated about call of duty
Caine say ways to run at that smooth 60
area another thing too like I see people
saying like why would you buy this it's
just the campaign remastered that's kind
of dumb why would you you don't have to
buy it like if you've got modern warfare
2 you just pop it in and play it if you
want it's you know what there's some
people out there who want to and if you
want to go for it you know I'll tell you
right now I'm not buying this I've got
too many other games I'm playing right
now oh and way too many other games
like as much nostalgia sigh have for
enjoying Modern Warfare 2 s campaign I'm
not itching to play it again III do
there is I'm curious cuz yeah it does
feel like the timings weird we're like
you could have put it out when there was
like nothing else happening right yeah
so I don't think this is the burger town
level I think the next level is the
burger town level or maybe this level
ends with Burger town I don't know we'll
find out um yeah I'll buy the
multiplayer when it comes out though
I'll play that yeah and maybe if they
pack this in like as an extra thing with
the multiplayer when it gets released if
it does get released I'll bite maybe
I'll bleed up a bit how do you get on
this you just gotta go to your
PlayStation and find it on the store
purchase give the get a cool purchase
going and download the thing and you're
off to go do you think that should
remaster on the other Call of Duty's I
was saying earlier I'd love to see more
black ops games remastered especially
one one is like my favorite Call of Duty
that'd be a good one
actually in just because it sounds like
a I said remaster the original ecology
where you asked to call duty one and two
not two would be green yester oh I love
Commissioner big red one me master like
just do the call of duty world war two I
never played big red one because that
was a campaign thing or a console thing
it was a good time but I go for those
especially because the original Call of
Duty doesn't even have like bounding
health it's that old yeah it's also kind
of hard to like get like I tried to play
a couple years ago and it kept crashing
or having weird issues when I try to
like up the framerate and stuff so yeah
like a version of that that would just
like easily play would be kind of nice
like take out the health kits maybe bump
up the animations and textures a bit
have a pretty good time yeah but
definitely - oh man I would love a love
it - oh wait that's one of my guys just
gotta give him a little tap on the
shoulder hey man you're doing a good job
yeah Cole I'd like to see call duty -
remastered so it doesn't have infinite
spawns oh yeah that was the last time I
ever got really frustrated at a game was
trying to finish that game on the
hardest difficulty
dumar warfare one had the infinite
spawns in some rooms as well like I
remember that TV station the grenades
think out the healthkit so it's probably
game back then you know actually that's
a fair point I'm just thinking like what
I would want my god yeah I would keep
telling them kids and and one if they
were to do it I'd be okay with health
get still I'd like to see them kind of
modernize it I guess is what I'm getting
at like I love a faithful remaster so we
could actually play it the way it's
supposed to be played but I also kind of
want to just even even halo with its
parts that had health kits had abounding
health system on top oh yeah shield yeah
dude what are you doing keep David come
on chillin
my man get in here here we make some
remasters yeah you guys still checking
out your Animal Crossing island you
betcha dude every day Gordon you know it
my shop opened up there selling a
captain's hat it's the only handle
everywhere from now on feeling good oh
no there is burger town
we made it we've found it we've gotta go
stop stop them from invading the burger
town do you think uh in this world's
universe like year years in the future
everyone remembered that as like a key
point to battle like remember the Alamo
everyone's like Oh remember the burger
200 everything looked dark and grim
until we took that Burger town back like
we had a real good foothold there
there's like a memorial like left there
like to keep the sign and they had like
a giant memorial and people come and
leave flowers at the burger town and the
Nate yeah no one remembers the Nate's as
well as the burger tab no one remembers
Nate's like burger to know it doesn't
have quite the same ring to it oh it's
because it almost got blown up there's
not much left of Nate
it's keeping the the health kits in
because it punishes you if you mess up I
mean yeah I guess like I'm down for
whatever like I'll play it again with
the health kits it wasn't that difficult
why can't every first-person-shooter
just be doomed 2016 yeah let's just do
that okay sure
you've got a travel the Nazis to get
your health back and just constantly
move forward all the time it's
impressive that you're able to find that
ladder with that giant gun some people
calling out to shoot the gas station oh
[Music]
dang I might be too late so good we came
to go
tako to go oh man
what do you think this year's ecology
will be or should be about the bigot Nam
war called it again the big will the big
rumor is they're gonna remake they're
gonna remake black ops and and it's
gonna have more of an emphasis on the
Vietnam War or something I I'm sure I
forget exactly what the rumor said I
know it's like they're gonna
supposedly remake black ops you're gonna
you're gonna get all your boys in there
your res knobs you're Alex million woods
I just if they do I still want it to be
is crazy and over-the-top and like weird
like changing the book alternate history
stuff I hope they get back gary oldman
for Rezanov there you go well that war
apparently was a really good Call of
Duty that I sort of missed out I liked
where that war the Russian campaigns a
real cheesy in a way that I'm super into
cuz yeah that's where Rezanov is from
he's like to recognize him and I played
a lot of the zombie he's like their
version of Captain Price yeah and he's
like he's just putting on the cheesiest
Russian accent it's it's so good
hello just got a knife all these guys as
I keep coming up so good way to do it
neck when melee hits were one hit kills
[Music]
that's the gun that's the sniper rifle
right there that's a good one nope never
right
never mind does this ps4 yes this is on
ps4 right now this time make is only
available on PlayStation 4 but it will
be on the Xbox and PC in a month the
magic appearing knife that comes out of
nowhere that's the good stuff
no explanations no way around it take
over that diner to black ops 1 zombies
was like the pika zombies for me I love
the base stage in that one a lot and I
loved the one campaign with all the like
the just running around hearing though
like impersonations of Richard Nixon and
oh yeah they're really good it's not one
it's five its I'm all over the place
yeah yeah it's called five yeah that's a
good one I love it
don't worry CB our financial will help
me what what if games just started to do
this is going off of what Brent family
said what if what if games like Call of
Duty did do like like a Smash Brothers
ultimate where there's just like
everyone's here and it's it's just a
game with every Call of Duty map every
Call of Duty gun oh I was thinking um
like the campaign would just be like
every character from every Call of Duty
just appears in the campaign somehow
like you're it's it's like a weird like
the time stream is broken and you have
like Rezanov and Alex Mason running
through like a world war two map like
the the African front and then just
finally shows up yeah exactly like
that's kinda what the zombies Canon is I
guess just have the zombies people
accidentally stumble into like Captain
Price and Rezanov and we need you
starfox come and save the day take them
away in a portal I'm offered to us the
original one did this one does not this
one is just the campaign so far you
don't know if anything else is getting
at it later on okay
what are you guys thinking of trimming
tomorrow I don't know sure tomorrow's
Wednesday the big major release for this
week is Friday
persona came out yesterday today ah
technically and it's up to what Persia
decides to do that's really what it
boils down to it's literally just
Ramirez do everything
is it worth to buy so far I I wouldn't
buy it personally but her are you
enjoying it I mean it's good it's it's
call of duty modern warfare two's
campaign which I I'm still fun time with
I would say like you know if you're
really really itching to play Modern
Warfare 2 again you want it to look
nicer
it's it's certainly not a bad deal or
about that package but I mean if you
know also say if if you've never played
Modern Warfare 2 s campaign $20 isn't a
bad Buy in for this good-looking version
of it no it's definitely not cuz I think
it still probably cost like 15 if you
were to buy it backwards compatible an
Xbox for example so yeah I could be
wrong about that but I want to say it's
15 I still think what's gonna happen is
they're going to they've got this out
the campaign for $20 the multiplayer for
$20 and then SpecOps for 10 and then
they're gonna do a full release after
all that's out I feel like that would be
the play but again it's it's just
guessing
Oh Scott says should I get doom eternal
yeah we're play the first one but it
looks fun yeah good time
I'd say get doom eternal if it looks
good to you you're probably gonna have a
very good time with it and then
afterwards definitely pick up 2016
because it's on sale for like five bucks
all the time yeah and have even more fun
personally I think I like 2016 more than
eternal but eternal is very very good
people hitting on predator hunting
grounds
it's okay those problems from a virus
released like III enjoyed a little bit
that I played and it is a beta so I feel
like they're taking whatever feedback
people are giving them now and kinda for
forming it around it's it's not that's
not the final product is there's still
time yeah it's early access right yeah
and I also like that between predator
hunting grounds and also project
resistance resistance I can call it that
oh no the Nathans no that's right no it
arose in Athens that's exactly but
between those we've got a whole bunch of
asymmetrical multiplayer games coming
out they're pretty good yeah we gotta
secure the bridge that's what it was
Nathan's got blown up so the burger town
could hit live but I really like
Resident Evil resistance
I kind of almost like I wish that I
could get it separate from our III it's
weird
it is a separate download is it yeah
it's got weird I have I had to get a
separate download code maybe they will
offer it separately I don't know that
was kind of weird they would have said
it by this point I think like it comes
with it hmm but it's weird to me that it
was a separate download that makes me
interest cool my my main thing is I'm
playing re 3 on the PC when my code
comes in that I've ordered from a site
but all my friends that want to play
resistance are on ps4 so I'm like sure
hope I don't have to buy that game twice
I'd be real nice if I could just like
buy resistance or something separately I
was just not making months ago after him
good job good job keeping it secret yeah
it all kind of fell apart like yesterday
but epic a shot one of my dates yeah
that happens watched an ru resistance
stream we did one a long time ago for
the closed beta we did if people are
interested we could do that on Friday if
people really want it I just I don't
know I no one seemed to really care much
for it so I was sort of like yeah well
you know maybe we just won't bother them
I think it's it's definitely one of
those things that doesn't like it it
doesn't look as good when you're
watching someone play it but it's fun
while you're playing it
but I mean if we got if we got people
who want to play it I'd be down for it
on that though an excuse to play pika so
isn't it is a good excuse to play in a
vo booth sang squad I've made it to the
Burger town meat locker like no no Keith
Keith could you see that again but with
more conviction this time yeah we
thought I've made it to the burger time
we really want you to sell the
desperation and you know relief that
you've made it to the Burger town meat
locker
making it make it sound like you're out
of breath like you just ran across an
entire parking guy all of America is on
your shoulders right now
but it's okay because you've made it to
the burger tab here's the scene Keith
David Russia is invaded you happily get
to burger town
I mean isoprene against your made
instead of remakes remasters yeah
angry seems like there are a lot of
remakes happening recently
I mean I'll say the 2r is an evil breeze
credit it's it's not it's very different
obvious mine one-to-one remasters either
to be honest like I like them when like
it's a game that you can't easily access
anymore or plays easily so I was
thinking about the other day with resin
evil where I was like blue thee if they
were to remaster what would they
remaster next right and you're like oh
dronicus a good one right and you're
like well for would be a good one and I
was thinking about it and I was like
what I actually want them to change
anything about four because I think four
is a perfect game and yeah like if you
were to tell me like hey we've
remastered Resident Evil 4 it's in the
re engine so it looks hot as [ __ ] but
other than that it's the exact same I'd
be like okay perfect all on board I
don't need you to change anything about
that like that's the case right I almost
wouldn't want you to change anything if
the spire one Crash Bandicoot remasters
were good yeah a Spyro will steal so
much
[Music]
imagine being that guy who just got shot
at and then it was like okay cool now
it's time for me to move
oh no that's guy at least I got one shot
off imagine if we got a like a predator
game but done in the style of like
shadow Mordor a shadow war
I like that like kind of like a like an
open-world with like maybe even a
Nemesis system type of thing where
you've got certain soldiers that you run
in with a whole bunch like taking
templates for things that I like and
putting them on other things now that
totally and just dreaming of what could
happen I want a Joe Joe fighting game
made by the guilty gear people in the
guilty gear engine yeah I think I think
we all do yeah yeah there's again
there's the no on line in this it's just
the campaign no SpecOps $20 ps4 month of
exclusivity
is that a hind and this kind of weather
it's rougher look what's a Russian
gunship doing here outside of this
burger town that's my uh my only been a
metal gear I'm alive do okay okay I
can't tell if they're good or not no no
not the taco joint oh you couldn't
what's the actual evil taco joint I
forget taco - yeah you should have said
you should've said taco - go
what if there are two taco things there
yeah
deadly neurotoxin says you guys are
great thanks for the commentary while
playing we bounded back and I feel so
good
you did it I'm about to die though do
appreciate comments like that cuz it it
gets rough sometimes you know kiss it's
rough oh here Heidi
okay so I gotta get to the Nathan oh
yeah demon slayers getting a game from
the Naruto guys Naruto Naruto Todd I I
swear I'm not trying to offend literally
everyone who loves that show I've just
said it that way so much and I try to
say it better I try I try to do it
correctly
Naruto Jason Naruto baloney Kenshin God
definitely reordering this you just
order it it's out now you don't need to
pre-order it unless you don't own a ps4
watch guys oh yeah that is a pre-order
shoot I jumped to a conclusion again
it's a skin for ghost in the recent
modern warfare game it also comes with
yeah it also comes with blueprints for
two weapons from modern warfare 2 we
have it on xbox
update that would do it got him I should
probably watch Demon Slayer a lot of
people really like it ah tried it it's a
little slow start couldn't get into it
I'm willing to give him another chance
though yes I wonder what dumb what dumb
like garbage my brain was on earlier
this week her blast later last week so
playing the the new one-piece Musso
because of course I was and I was like
you would be a good idea uh well we're
stuck in our homes
why don't I watch all in one fist hey
man I'm the realization hit me so hard
that I physically like like pulled
myself backwards like I had to like hold
on you're like oh god this quarantines
hitting me harder than I thought yeah I
almost decided to watch all of one piece
Jesus I know that I'd love it I know I
would
it's just 900 I can't commit to bed
Gintama is 500 that that's still a lot I
love that oh yeah Adam it is the
campaign only whoa all right we did it
we successfully defended burger town I
think we can call this a stream although
through 15 more minutes so we'll we'll
keep going yeah I watched all 30 rock in
one week 30 rock is really good it's a
very like a very very bendable show but
also yeah if you're like Musso games
that new one-piece one maybe one of the
best moves are games that are out there
I paid $20 it will give me the skin even
though it says it's installed huh maybe
restart your system or something I have
no idea to troubleshoot it but hope you
I hope it it works out though do I skin
isn't usable in the war zone doesn't
show up I know if it's me but do they
rush to do you arrest evil 3 didn't
really come out maybe I mean res evil 3
is also not like this big a game as
Resident Evil 2 like even the originals
what do you get for purchasing games so
you get the remastered modern warfare 2
campaign no multiplayer no SpecOps and
you also get a a special ghost skin for
modern warfare 2 weapon blueprints like
an emblem and a card like a usual a
usual pack for just like modern warfare
character stuff yeah oh yeah this is
this is very real boy demon they they
put it up there's no multiplayer there's
no spec ops in it yet if they are doing
it but just the campaign is here should
they make modern warfare 2 cross plate
that's what we were thinking yeah that'd
be cool like what if they were making
the multiplayer cross play and they
can't put out the multiplayer til
everyone else gets it a month later so
we would happen then maybe maybe fun
Theory gonna need some lunch knowledge
back tomorrow all right Brandon take it
easy thanks for hanging out enjoy your
lunch
see you later
some ovary maker remastered its a
remaster yeah I guess it's it's pretty
much the same thing just with better
textures and runs better I mean it's so
weird because there's like a spectrum
like you know remake is like one end
right where it's like okay we've
completely redone it that's like a
resident evil 3 right remake we've
completely remade it then you have on
the lower end of the spectrum you have
like a remaster where maybe just like
hey it's the exact same game but now
it's in 1080p like higher frame rate
right like a like a Yakuza 3 4 & 5
collection right this kind of sits
somewhere in the middle where it's like
it's the same game they haven't changed
anything about it but they've completely
overhauled and re updated all of the
graphics so I would say it kind of sits
somewhere in the middle
we're playing modern warfare 2 and PC
when it came out our computer wasn't
very good so I had to play it that's a
very 480p resolution it was still their
favorite game regardless that's that's
the power of a game II enjoy I remember
playing battlefield 2 on a PC that
didn't run it very well and also having
to make a lot of weird concessions for
graphical fidelity still one of my
favorite multiplayer games I've ever
played kind of a that kind of a similar
situation I miss I miss playing
battlefield as much as I used to yeah I
just battlefield 5 didn't didn't hit the
way I wanted it to like I was like
really excited I was like oh man let's
get back into it like they're gonna go
over the top with it at one point it
seemed and then they scale the back yeah
I don't know just something about it
just it's hard to put my finger on
exactly what it is that just didn't work
because because I went back and replayed
like a little bit of 3 a little bit of 4
and actually really enjoyed replaying
those those were really good I had a fun
time with those yeah Barry wants to know
what our thoughts are on ghosts of
Tsushima got Tsushima I'm excited to
play it big same it looks really good
very beautiful I have no idea how they
came supposed to be set up a played but
it from what I can see it looks like
it's an open-world kind of hack and
slash game right that's enough for me to
be sold on it very excited about it
there are a lot of people who still play
battlefield 4 there are I think I was
the last one they kind of like played
please four and three people still play
both of those yeah
there are so people can play even like
bad company - Oh bad company choose
where it's at man that game is a [ __ ]
yeah I I miss the bad company series
there's just something about like those
games attitude mixed with the like
really good battlefield game play yeah
like who's multiplayer is fantastic but
I also really love just like the dumb
story of these dudes who are just trying
to get gold yeah good good old
characters I the the thing I always
wanted them to do was I wanted them to
do that company 21:42 yeah it's but it's
C and it's the exact same characters
from Bad Company but they're in space
and they got to get space gold and they
sit there and sometimes they question it
and then someone's like nah don't even
think about it it's fine yeah like it
doesn't make any sense it's just those
characters but now they're in space and
space gold yeah Oh double peril in this
one the one of the best things about
that series of games - is the marketing
for it
so just I mention him before but they
just made fun of all the other games
that were coming out around the time
yeah so did like parody commercials of
like years of war and Metal Gear Solid
Rainbow six they parodied that like it
literally just be like like it showed
one of the characters running through
the street and you just hear like his
friend behind him singing mad world by
Gary Jules and as the song eventually
coming in he's like shut up we're trying
to sneak on these guys he's I gots a
very moody song it's just if you can
find him you should definitely look them
up I highly recommend them
just like Bad Company parody commercials
just
there's a good games the legendary 1887
hekia you what I
I agree gorilla I'd go for a Max Payne
remaster bring bring 1 & 2 up Oh would
that be good to still plays really well
and it's got it's not bad on PC but yeah
I love one it too
I've been meaning to replay 3 actually I
really like it's very like street soon
it's a very different game and I can
totally understand somebody not liking
it if they played one in two and we're
looking for more of that but I actually
really like 3 I will play through three
just to get to that airplane scene again
for the airport scene at the very end
yeah just just for the wind win the
winner
the heat the soundtrack kicks in it's
real good
Max Payne movie remaster pop Jones get
out oh god no attention game would be
really good we got Sakura which is 10
shoe but 10 shoe
esque yeah this game is actually getting
remastered it's it's I guess they
remastered the campaign so far it's it's
here today on ps4 you guess as if I've
not been playing it for the last hour
and a half I mean I guess invent like
it's not the full game right like it's I
can't say that it's all of modern
warfare 2 shirts just the campaign
I think max being the original would
definitely benefit from a remake because
there's a lot of like that game getting
it to run on PC now is a bit of a
headache sort of I sometimes I don't
even need a game necessary would be like
remastered I just needed to like Ron's
run it there's a really great company
called night dive studios that
specializes in like taking very old
obscure PC games and just getting them
to run again they're the guys who got
system shock and system shock 2 to run
on Gog and steam on like modern systems
before those games were like notoriously
like hard tickets run and they had all
sorts of like weird legal issues that
prevented them from even like coming out
and that studio got those games to run
they actually Delson to the excellent
ports of Turek 1 & 2 and they they're
the ones who did the the doom 64 port
that comes free with the doom eternal so
like those guys do some good work
they're also the ones who are actually
doing the remake of System Shock 1 they
technically owned the system shocks
license like they got the whole license
in order to port those games yes Empire
this is this is real it is just the
campaign though no multiplayer no
SpecOps and only on ps4 for the time
being out today announced today
I love this can beer it's really funny
shoot
this this dream also went by really
quick yeah a good time yeah just uh I
just looked at the time and realized how
how late it was
do we want to wrap up this level and
then call it so maybe go a little bit
past busy today I'm just so busy being
locked inside of my house I don't know
what I'm gonna do with myself
there but now I'm down to at least
finish the level heck yeah
there's a great stream thank you Bob
appreciate it I'm still really stoked
that John Luke figured out how to get a
stream working so he could still do
shows even in our quarantined lifestyle
we all live yeah it's a lot more
involved than you think it would be just
because of the the nature of how we
stream and us trying to coordinate with
each other and like I had to
troubleshoot this morning trying to get
Ben audio so he could hear the game as
well yeah technically he's streaming to
two different places right now and we're
on a discord call yeah there's a lot
streaming the game to him through
discord so that he can see some
commentator yeah but you made it work
and it's it's a solid stuff it it's a
real good time I'm not finished yet
I yeah we got it we got to go away
eventually I've got people hitting me up
hit me up on slack telling me that they
got videos for me to publish I got I got
it I got some some big old stuff I got
to take care of yeah
suppose that jumpin if I remember that
it will stop happen anyway you have to
like run through the the favela they
found you yeah as much as I'd love to
sit here and stream all day
unfortunately my real my real work calls
Sam so what will you do is we just need
to get like get as many people into the
stream as possible because we could then
make a case like abba third there are
like 500 people watching we got to keep
going otherwise we'll lose the numbers
then we can keep going that's how you
justified if we have a higher view count
we can then say hey leave these people
hanging yeah wonder one thick nordic
will talk about timesplitters same yeah
forgot thank god lad I'd love the time
splitters anything I just been so long
say I I bought the new the new home
front game just so I can play like the
what three levels that are in it yeah
that's how much I want I'm good man yeah
well that is actually the perfect dumb
to call it which is uh I'm not sure what
the next level is but I know I think
we're close to okay so it's not the next
one okay I felt bad if the next one was
the prison level because yeah a very
good level but yeah I think we're gonna
call it here thank you for watching
everybody
really appreciate it it's been a fun
stream you know like yeah it's pretty
much exactly what you think it is it's
just modern warfare 2 looking better
running on modern systems it's only it's
20 bucks on in the US which is a pretty
decent price but I mean if you like
Modern Warfare's campaign
you're itching to play it again look
better there you go if not and uh at
least you've now seen what it looks like
yeah and also please I can't stress it
enough if you do like what you saw
please subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss any of the shows we do yeah
every week today 2 p.m. Pacific
I'm not gonna do our show on Fridays
where we play games with you maybe
Resident Evil maybe Phantasy Star Online
2 who knows you only know once you show
up well guys thank you for watching and
we will catch you next time